Hello and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan. And today, we
kick off a new course, the complete guide
to Parca.
Before I tell you what Parca is, let's
set the scene. So So if you've been
working in the infrastructure,
operations,
bare metal, cloud computing, DevOps,
any of these professions,
then the likelihood is you've spent a lot
of your time looking at graphs like this.
Now this is an extreme situation which has
been contrived to walk you through an introduction
to Parca. This is a graph that shows
the CPU consumption across our infrastructure.
And as you can see something happened within
the last hour.
Our CPU has spiked from under one utilization,
one core being consumed at all time to
now approaching four.
Now because this is a contrived situation, I
know that this is a new deployment with
a new version of our software and I
want to show you how you can take
a signal like this and use Parca to
understand what changed within your application
and help you lower that mean time to
resolution.
So let's learn about Parca.
Parca is a continuous
profiler.
If you're not aware or you haven't done
profiling before, this is a tool that monitors
for your application's profiles.
Typically for Go applications we expose a PPROF
endpoint
that prints out a whole bunch of diagnostic
information that you can consume to understand the
Go runtime itself.
Parca takes that to the next degree.
Parca runs full time non stop
consistently
inside of your Kubernetes cluster or on bare
metal if you wish
and monitors your application.
However, it doesn't require you to have a
pprof endpoint
or to use Go. Parca is quite sophisticated.
It uses this new shiny technology.
I say new but recent shiny technology called
eBPF.
This allows it to hook into the kernel
using probes
to understand what's actually happening within your application
without you having to instrument anything yourself.
This means it can track the memory, the
CPU, the IO and even the network and
utilization
down to the function call of your application
and show you what's actually happening under the
hood. So when we see graphs with extreme
deviation on it, we can rely on Parca
to tell us what is going on. So
let's dive in and take a look at
using Parca to resolve our current CPU utilization
problem. So the first thing we want to
do is get Parca installed to our cluster.
To do so, you can click the quick
start guide here, which takes you to the
Parca documentation.
You can, if you wish, curl and run
a binary on your machine. The first thing
I'll cover is that Parca comes in two
parts.
One, the Parca server.
This is a database that will store all
of the profiling information,
provide a simple UI that will allow you
to explore this and understand what's happening with
your applications.
The second part is the agent.
Again, can download this as a binary and
run it in all of the machines within
your infrastructure
or you can deploy it to your Kubernetes
cluster with some Kubernetes YAML. If you scroll
to the top and select Kubernetes,
you'll see that we can now create the
Parca namespace,
deploy the server which comes with the API
and the user interface
and then the agent which gets deployed as
a daemon set to every node within your
cluster. It's really simple to get Parca deployed
and running within your infrastructure especially
if you're using Kubernetes.
So I've already installed Parca, so let's head
over to my terminal where we can run
kubectl,
filter to the Parca namespace
and get pods.
Here we have the Parca server running, that's
the first pod on the list followed by
a agent
which is deployed as a daemon set. Because
it's deployed as a daemon set and because
I had three nodes in my cluster, we
get three copies of the agent. These agents
are the ones that are responsible for deploying
the eBPF probes
to the kernel to allow us to understand
all of the processes running on each of
these machines.
From here,
we can run kubectl
arca
get service
where you see we have a cluster IP
service running on port seventy seventy.
When you port forward to this, you get
the Parca UI.
So let's jump back to our browser
and see the Parca UI. From here, you
can select targets and you'll see that the
agent is deployed to all three nodes within
my cluster.
We can see when it last scraped and
how long the scrape itself took. If we
head back to profiles,
we can now get CPU samples
and begin to filter
on any dimension that we wish, at least
any dimension that is available and scraped by
the Parca agent.
However,
you can also just click search and get
visibility
into the CPU consumption of all the processes
on your host. And as we can see
here, we have a bit of a runaway
problem with one of the pods within our
cluster.
Now consuming over six CPUs.
So let's hover on one of the points
within the runaway process. From here, we can
see the CPU value and this point exactly
is 5.37.
We can see the duration and we see
the labels or dimensions applied to this process.
This actually allows us to understand the executable
that was run and the pod that it
was running. Here we can see that the
executable was app.
Now if these are third party pods, you
may not understand or be able to use
the executable to understand and even more about
this process. However, the pod name should give
you everything else that you require.
Here, we can see that the pod that
is running away with the CPU utilization of
this machine is a million dollar app pod.
This is my one application that I have
deployed to the cluster and I should understand
exactly what is happening in my code. Right?
Well, wrong.
Unfortunately,
in 2023
and so and at least for the last
ten years, Applications are comprised primarily of open
source libraries
and then a small bit probably written by
you and your team or your organization.
We don't really have great visibility into the
dependencies our application use. Think of the last
time you ran a GoGet, an NPM install,
a PEP install,
a gem bundle and so forth. Did you
look at the source code of all of
the dependencies that you're pulling in to make
your life easier?
The chances are no. So what do you
do if one of those dependencies
is starting to consume more memory, more network,
more disk IO or more CPU?
Well, we need more visibility
and this is where Parca shines.
Let's go to our CPU samples where we
can see filter on pod
and we're going to see million dollar pod.
And if we get the pod ID from
here, we can see that it's BCLCC.
We can click search to only reveal this
one unique series.
Now what's really nice about Parca, which is
kind of hidden by the zoomed in rate
at the moment,
is that we get an icicle graph below.
This shows you the functions where the CPU
is spending the most time. The longer the
bar, the more time the CPU has spent
there.
And it drills down like an icicle so
that you can follow the CPU consumption from
function to function across your stack. And actually,
we'll zoom back in and if we scroll
down, we'll see that if we hover on
the root,
a % of our time is spent there.
Of course, because everything else within our application
is a child or descending of the root
function. If we work our way down, we
can see the number start to get lower
and lower.
And if we look down here, we can
see it's substantially lower.
What we're looking for is that inflection point
where we go from the most CPU
down to distributed CPU cycles.
And as we can see here,
the million dollar dependency
is calling two functions.
One, Feb and one, addition.
These are both consuming 86%
of our CPU. And if and below this
is substantially less, meaning the root cause or
where most of the consumption is happening is
probably within these two functions.
What I love about this icicle graph
is that visually we can identify the bad
actors or the bad functions or the not
necessarily malicious,
but the code that we need to optimize
very very quickly. And the icicle graph isn't
the only way to present this information.
If you really want, you can filter by
table. So when we filter by table, we
still get the cumulative sum for how much
time is spent in each of the functions.
And we can see a large drop off
between the addition function
and then any other function below it going
from 83,000
down to 41,000.
Again,
signifying
that the addition function
with the largest deviation between the next caller
probably has the problem that we want to
fix. So I think it's about time we
take a look at some code. Let's pop
over to Versus Code
and open our main dot go. This is
our million dollar application.
It is a simple HTTP handler that calls
some dependencies
function called addition.
That's all this application does. Again, everything else
is open source and by open source, it's
my own dependency that I've stuck in place.
However, remember,
when's the last time you looked at the
source code of any of your open source
dependencies you consume within your application? I bet
the answer is never. So let's pop open
dApp because we know that this addition function
is the root cause or potential root cause
of whatever is happening
to degrade the performance of our application. And
when we open this, we see some very
simple code. It's using the HTTP request object
to grab I and j and convert them
to an integer. And if we scroll down,
we then see some rather interesting code. For
some weird reason,
this open source dependency that we're consuming has
decided to open a loop for a very
large number to calculate the Fibonacci sequence.
As you can see, there's also the Fib
function.
These are the two things we've seen in
our CPU profiles.
We've seen the call to addition was consuming
a lot of CPU. We also seen the
feb call consuming just as much CPU,
which now makes sense that we're looking at
the code. We can see the loop. We
see the function call. We got all of
this from an uninstrumented
application.
Let's just clarify that again.
This is four lines of Go code with
some imports and package metadata.
We haven't instrumented this with metrics, logs, tracing,
nothing. Yet Parca using eBPF
is able to understand
the stack pointers within our Go application and
give us so much visibility for free. Now
this application only has one single dependency which
is a million dollar debt with this addition
function. However, your application
likely has dozens,
hundreds or even thousands of dependencies calling dozens,
hundreds or thousands of dependent functions.
Using Parca,
you can understand the CPU profile of all
of that without changing a single line of
code and that is ridiculously powerful. So let's
deploy effects removing our terrible
dependency.
We delete the Fibonacci call, we delete the
Fibonacci function,
we can rebuild this image and deploy it
to a cluster. I'm going to spare you
that little bit of boring typing in the
terminal and fast forward directly
to Parca again where we look at v
two of our application. So here we are.
We can still see the old CPU consuming
workload which hasn't been running for, the last
five minutes. However,
we can't actually see the new version of
our deployment because the utilization is so normal.
It blends in with everything else within the
cluster. But, of course, we can use the
compare button. So let's grab our million dollar
application
with the broken version
and click search. Here, we can grab the
million dollar application with the correct version and
hit search. Now we can see the two
lines side by side. We can see over
here where it fluctuated from, like, anywhere from
six to 6.5.
And over here, it's going from zero to
0.1.
With the comparison, we can actually scroll down
to take a look at the icicle graph
where we can see that everything below the
serve function was worse with the older version
and everything is now better with the new
version. Perfect.
If this deploy went the other way and
we wanted to see what changed
from the old version to the new version,
we can of course pop over and switch
these around. From here, we can see search
and search. And now we can see that
the application is worse on every single layer.
And again, we can identify fib and addition
as a potential cause of this degradation.
So that's Parca. Parca instruments your code and
allows you to understand what's happening down to
the function level with no changes on your
part. But if we pop open our drop
down here, we see the only option is
CPU samples.
And I said something at the start of
this video, which is that Parker can help
you not just with CPU, but with memory,
disk IO and even network. So where are
these settings? Well, at the moment, with the
auto instrumentation with eBPF,
only CPU samples are supported,
but more will be coming soon. If you
want to have access to the extra instrumentation,
you need to provide a pay professor endpoint.
So let's see how to do that for
a Go application
now.
Let's head back to Versus Code where we
have the easiest,
simplest Go code in the world. We could
scroll down to our imports where we import
net HTTP
pprof.
That's quite hard to say. And guess what?
We're done. Let's rebuild this and push v
three to our cluster. So now that our
application has been instrumented
using
the default HTTP handler with Go and importing
the PPROF package, we can then go to
Parca to consume those extra profiles.
So if we click on the drop down
here for select profile where it used to
be just CPU samples, we now have access
to the number of Go routines created,
memory allocated objects and bytes and memory and
use object and bytes. Now because we're doing
this via the Parca agent and via the
pprof endpoint within our Go application, we're going
to end up with the original CPU samples
but then a duplicate of process CPU samples
and process CPU
nanoseconds.
Now there are ways to configure the Parca
agent to avoid certain workloads within your cluster,
meaning when you instrument your own applications with
PPROF endpoints, you can attach labels to the
deployments and tell the Parca agent not to
scrape or not to use eBPF instrumentation
on those workloads. In a video later on
in this course, we'll be taking a look
at the more advanced configuration techniques for such
deployments.
But for right now, let's just do a
simple exploration of the go routines, the memory
allocated, and the memory in use. First, click
go routine created total and click search.
Now we've already seen the code for my
application.
It isn't actually spinning off any go routines
for us to see any fluctuation in this
graph at all. So you can see that
it's pretty static at six nonstop.
However, your application probably does use go routines
if you're writing in Go. So you'll be
able to visualize that in much more detail.
Moving down, we get to see the memory
allocated objects
total.
Now when I click search here, what we
should actually see is an incremental
linear line, hopefully linear
and if we click search, there we go.
Now this is the total allocated objects across
the entire lifespan of this pod, so we
would expect that to only go up or
at least stop if there were no traffic,
it wasn't being consumed,
it wasn't doing anything useful.
Perhaps idle time. We can then see the
same for the bates total.
So while we have lots of allocated objects,
the base total may be slightly different depending
on what those objects looks like within your
code and it's vital to understand both the
shape and the size of the thing happening
within your application. Now that's the total values
over all time but what if you want
to see what your application looks like right
now as a snapshot?
Well, we can use n use bytes and
n use objects. We click search and we'll
see that this will go up and down
depending on what's happening with our application.
So while this looks relatively flat right now,
let's trigger some workloads, some requests against our
application.
So if we head over to the terminal,
I have a k six script.
If we pop this open,
you'll see that it just makes some requests
calling our addition function with a couple of
values, nothing particularly fancy.
But we can run this with 10 virtual
users for a duration of nine hundred seconds
or fifteen minutes,
like so. So this is going to send
a whole bunch of requests every single second
to our pod, which if we give it
just a few moments, we should be able
to head back on over to Parca and
see our memory utilization
both total and end use
change
from what we've had over the last five
to ten minutes.
Okay. So that's been running for a couple
of minutes now, so let's head back over
to Parca. Now if we go to the
go routine created total, what we should see
is well, even though our application doesn't use
a lot of go routines, the HTTP server
does depending on how many requests come in
and the number of processors available on the
machine. So if we click search,
as we can see when we started
the k six kind of load stressing process,
the number of goroutines did rise from six
to 16 where it has continued. So let's
go across and kill that,
like so. And we should see that our
go routines actually drop back down as we
go back into an idle state. Now our
h b endpoints are also very very simple,
so we're not gonna see huge fluctuations in
memory. However, if we go to the objects
total, we'll see that this continues to rise,
maybe just increasing a little bit with that
stress and load test tool running against it.
And the same for the baits, I would
imagine,
maybe slightly more consistent.
If we go to the end user's memory
and the objects and the baits here, these
will probably still continue to fluctuate again because
the http endpoints aren't allocating anything to the
heap. So we're just going to trust that
our profile information is doing exactly what we
want. Let's head back over to go routines
and see if we've reached our idle state
again.
Perfect. There we have it. I hope that
gives you a taste for what you can
start to do,
understand and achieve by deploying Parca to your
infrastructure.
It's a phenomenal tool that gives us a
new level of observability
that we haven't previously had
with so little instrumentation to be done to
the point of none. Alright?
If you just want to get Parca running
on your infrastructure,
deploy the agent, rely on the eBPF
instrumentation,
you can do that now. Don't need to
modify your applications and you'll begin to understand
at the function level how your application behaved
from release
to release and that is really important. Continuous
profiling is there to help you understand how
your software changes over time.
So in an upcoming video, we're gonna take
a look at a real production application
triggering the deployments from version to version using
profiling to understand
how the code that we commit affects the
performance of our application. And then if you
do want to go beyond CPU samples,
you can add PPROF endpoints to your application
to understand the memory, the network and the
disk IO consumption or patterns of your applications
too. Join us for the next video as
we take a look at taking all of
this new understanding and observability
and putting it in to the home of
the rest of our observability
data.
Namely, Grafana. Parca has fantastic support for working
with the Grafana ecosystem and we'll see that
in the next video. Until then, have fun
playing with Parca and we'll see you all
next time. Have a great day.